c'est ainsi toute actualité et allez
c'est parti je me fais un petit kiff
alors c'est mon jeu préféré
alors vous explique ah ouais merde non
c'est la gueule alors je vous explique
donné la responsable c'est pourquoi le
premier ministre edouard philippe fils
maki lui offrir ce week end capois
position il a raconté une blague
il a faim lapsus il a oublié le nom du
président où il a vu jacques chirac à
bisié ans patrick chirac est ce qui
s'est passé ça dubosc à votre avis je
vais oublier le nom du président non non
il a il a réussi à tourner alors en fait
pour donner la bonne réponse il faut que
j'arrive à faire
[Rires]
cette folie
et à
[Applaudissements]
les chéris deuxième question attention à
la 73e minute de jeu franck on va voir
si vous avez réalisé toute la cub le
défenseur du real madrid sergio ramos a
dû quitter précipitamment le terrain
contre l'équipe delbarre sa femme allait
accoucher réponse à il s'est fait
courser par un supporter inverse adverse
il a taclé larbitre permis à de vertes
ans où il a du fond c'est faire popo
j'ai vu le match mais à thuram ou alors
s'est fait courser par un supporter non
c'est simplement je me sens à leur
passion
ah ouais
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon franck question laura cortesi que
l'on a pu voir dans ce vote ce week-end
et la demi-soeur de louise bourgoin
la nièce de marc lavoine la cousine de
géraldine nakache ou la 27e fille de
benjamin castaldi
alors la pièce el djazaïr c'est ce que
m'a suivi the voice ouais mais pas non
je me fais mal ou pas tu sais j'aime
bien je regarde mais j'ai pas c'est là
qu'elle leur accorde saisit alors
c'était la nièce de qui la voit pas du
tout la fdj
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou tu peux pas faire ça j'adore de
clasher tous les chroniqueurs de tpm
paix dans un livre laurence boccolini
dans une femme dans les médias
christophe beaugrand dans les coulisses
de la télé capucine à naftan authentique
ou gérard louvin comment bien choisir
sur monte escalier scan and view est pas
vous être anglais ohlala
[Applaudissements]
c'est un dominique sur le port de
djeddah les 106 rue nous en parler